uh this would be a whopper of a win the
mega millions has surged to 830 million
the third largest prize in the game's
history a lot of money all right and the
next drawing of course is happening
tonight and that's been a steady stream
of people heading over to prim to pick
up some of those tickets and that is
where we find las vegas now rocky
theaters with more hey rocky
hey you guys yes we are here in prim i'm
with amber eddie and ann you guys have
just gotten out of line after waiting
in the heat for hours three hours three
hours and i want to remind you there
were a few medical emergencies out there
you gotta stay hydrated bring some
snacks there's some machines in here if
you need it okay if you're getting down
here before five before they close now i
wanna talk to my group here okay so if
you won
the third largest jackpot
ever
mega millions what would you do with it
first things first well i pay off all my
bills take care of my family
and donate to saint jude no kid should
have to live with cancer so i have to
help
some organizations you know the homeless
yeah you know
after that have fun have fun have fun
not now i want to i want to point out he
did say i'll buy all my kids a house far
away from him too
that's not true though right yes that is
true
it is true look look we understand we
understand over here amber you know you
said you're in real estate but if you
won this lottery how would that change
anything
it would definitely change i'd invest in
my businesses that i'm currently doing i
take care of my family as well as donate
to charities i love that so invest in
yourself invest in your community get
down here five o'clock closing time i
want to remind you as well the scratcher
machines are officially closed the line
was just too long and again stay
hydrated eddie ann
you what's our group name
the lottery winners
i'll send it back to you